[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain the american
post-apocalyptic action-adventure film
called oblivion spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 2077 an alien species called the
scavengers plan to attack the earth for
its resources they first destroy the
moon causing a series of tsunamis and
earthquakes on earth as the humans
recover from the natural calamities the
scavengers attack them and a war breaks
out between the two species at last
humans eventually win the war using
nuclear weapons but as an aftermath the
earth is no longer habitable as most of
it turns into a radioactive wasteland to
survive the humans evacuate to one of
saturn's moons called titan this
evacuation is managed by officials who
inhabit a large spaceship in orbit
around earth called the tet tet has also
set up the hydro rig generators on the
earth these are used to generate sea
water and convert it into fusion energy
for the humans on titan the last two
people left on the earth are a couple
the husband jack harper and the wife
victoria live in a tower high above the
clouds they both work for the tet and
manage the hydro rig generators jack
serves as tech 49 whose job also
involves repairing the drones the device
designed to detect and terminate
remaining scavengers on earth victoria
mostly stays inside the tower to keep an
eye on him as his coordinator at the
beginning of the movie jack wakes up
from a dream of an unknown woman he has
been having recurring dreams for a long
time jack narrates that he doesn't
remember anything that happened before
the war as their memories were erased
for the mission's secrecy
the couple's mission on earth will be
over in two weeks after which they will
join the others on titan leaving the
earth with no more humans they continue
their normal morning routine after which
jack leaves for the regular inspection
of the scavenger killing drones he sees
that two of them have been damaged by
the scavengers overnight meanwhile
victoria contacts the mission director
from tet named sally she is reported to
about everything going on on earth by
victoria jack reaches the broken drone
and lands to repair it while victoria
helps him by monitoring the area for
scavengers jack successfully repairs the
drone even though he is short of
available equipment the drone quickly
flies away after scanning jack and
finding out he is not a threat jack then
searches for the second drone but is
disappointed when victoria tells him
that they have lost the beacon without
the beacon they have a hard time finding
the drone but an ambitious jack gets on
his bike to look for it he drives
through the plane lands that once used
to be the oceans and reaches a sinkhole
jack locates the second drone inside of
it but victoria asks him to leave it
because it is too dangerous however jack
ignores her and ties a rope to his bike
to go down the hole seeing this victoria
requests the mission control to send
backup to his location when jack reaches
the bottom he sees the remains of an old
building he somehow gets to the drone
but soon realizes that it is a trap set
by the scavengers they drag him by his
leg but jack uses his weapon and fights
back at last he is almost killed but the
backup drone arrives just in time it
kills all the scavengers and saves jack
after everything settles down jack
returns home jack has been growing a
flowery weed which he hands to victoria
as a gift to his disappointment she
throws it away saying that it might
contain toxins
been there at dinner jack reveals that
the scavengers were trying to capture
him today he is confused as to why they
wouldn't want to kill him victoria
however dismisses the conversation and
seductively invites him to the swimming
pool jack joins her a while later and
the night ends as they kiss or does it
the next morning they wake up to the
noise of a loud explosion jack quickly
gets on his jet and makes his way to the
area where the explosion took place
sally calls victoria and tells her that
one of the hydro rigs has had a meltdown
and has been destroyed permanently on
his way to the scene jack receives a
strange radio signal from an unknown
source it makes him curious so he makes
his way to the source of the said signal
he reaches the remains of the empire
state building which he often visits in
his recurring dream jack cuts a wire and
gets rid of the signal thinking it is of
use to the scavengers then he does a
perimeter check and almost crosses the
border to the radiation zone where they
aren't allowed to go before returning
home he goes to a house in the middle of
the woods that he had found on one of
his expeditions he comes here whenever
he feels down and has made the house his
own with decorations jack eventually
falls asleep and dreams of an unknown
girl in the empire state building a
while later he wakes up to see some sort
of vessel falling from the sky and
quickly gets in his jet at the same time
victoria contacted him to inform him
about the location of the vessel
victoria also contacts sally who tells
them to ignore the vessel because they
have already gone through a lot of
trouble for the day following the order
victoria asks jack to return home but he
dismisses her and lands on the crash
site there he notices that the capsule
is a pre-war device a confused jack
finds hibernation pods with humans
inside them he is even more surprised to
see that one woman inside a pod is the
girl he always sees in his dreams before
he can contemplate what is going on a
drone arrives there and begins shooting
the hibernation pod scanning them as
scavengers it destroys every pod but
jack stops it from killing the girl as
he transfers the girl to take her home
some scavengers from nearby watch him
back at the tower victoria is surprised
to see jack with the hibernation pod
they quickly get the girl out of the pod
and she calls jack's name before passing
out sometime later she gains
consciousness and introduces herself as
julie other than that she doesn't tell
them anything about her mission or her
crew while the three eat jack tells
julie about the war that caused the
humans to evacuate the earth he says
that julie must have been in that pod
for over 60 years but the girl just
laughs at the thought later at night
victoria tells jack that she wants julie
gone she wants to report her existence
to mission control and make them take
her to titan as well however jack
retaliates saying that the drones sent
by mission control tried to kill her so
asking them for help would be foolish as
they talk a scavenger from below the
tower keeps an eye on them
then we see julie looking at the horizon
through a window she asks jack to take
her to her ship to retrieve the flight
recorder she feels like she is in a
dream and has to know what happened to
her crew before the crash
jack hesitates declaring that the
scavengers are out on runs at night but
julie wants something exciting to happen
in the plot of this movie so she insists
at last they fly to the site of the
crash again a distressed victoria waits
for them at home unsettled by her
husband getting close to another woman
the other two reach the site and get the
recorder but before they can return they
are attacked and knocked out by the
scavengers
victoria sees this from the cameras and
freaks out the following morning she
gets a call from sally who asks her for
reports victoria doesn't tell her about
julie and makes up an excuse for jack
being absent meanwhile jack and julie
are tied up and taken to the scavengers
hideout to jack's surprise a human being
sits in front of him the man introduces
himself as malcolm beech and seems to
recognize jack he asks jack if he
remembers the things from his past but
jack says his memories were removed for
his own good then beech asks him if he
has ever seen a scavenger up close just
then the lights turn on and several
humans standing on platforms are seen
jack is surprised because he believed he
and victoria were the only ones left on
earth beach finally tells jack that the
scavengers they have been killing are
actually humans and the mission control
has been lying to him the thought is
incomprehensible to jack and he declares
it to be a lie then they take jack to
show him around the hideout and tell him
about their mission they want to destroy
the tet which is sucking out the earth's
resources for this purpose they have
brought down julia's ship odyssey
earlier the ship had explosives that had
the power to blow up the tet now they
have the explosives and they have a
drone to plant the explosives but the
only one who can program the drone is
jack hence they need his help jack
however retaliates saying that the tet
has human beings up there who he cannot
kill an enraged sergeant threatens to
kill julia if jack doesn't oblige right
then a drone arrives at the entrance of
the hideout and it scans for scavengers
beach takes jack out of the second
entrance and asks him to go to the
radiation zone to find the answers jack
and victoria have always been told to
stay out of the radiation zone so he
doesn't know what is on the other side
at last beech lets jack and julia go and
they fly to the empire state building
there jack tells her about his dreams
and to his surprise julia reveals that
she is his wife before everything went
down they were sent on a mission on a
research flight to titan the crew
consisted of five people in hibernation
pods while victoria and jack were
piloting the spaceship but before they
reached titan they discovered an alien
object in space that alien object was
tet julia has no memory of what happened
after that but jack begins to remember
the time he and julia were in love they
get closer to kiss but are interrupted
by jack's jet which has come to pick
them up victoria sees the two getting
close through the cameras and is
heartbroken when jack and julia return
to the tower victoria doesn't let them
in she reports to mission control about
julia and tells them jack is unfit for
service to their surprise the mission
control assigns a drone to kill both of
them because they are of no use anymore
the drone kills victoria but jack is
saved at the last minute he and julia
run away from the tower only to be
followed by the drones they get into an
intense battle in the sky and their jet
crash lands in the radiation zone jack
composes himself and sees a jet flying
overhead to his utter surprise another
jack comes out of the jet both of them
are completely in shock to see each
other the only difference between the
two is that jack's code number is tech
49 and the doppelgangers is tech 52 they
get into a fight and 49 quickly
overpowers 52 but julia is shot in the
process jack thinks of ways to save her
and gets on tech 52's jet he then flies
to tech 52's tower and meets his wife
victoria he acquires a healing device
from the tower and heads back to julia
to save her jack cannot comprehend that
behind the radiation zone is his
doppelganger living the same life as him
he and julia then drive to jack's fap
hut the lake house that jack always
visits the following day they return to
the scavengers hideout and meet beach
again beach finally reveals that tet is
actually an intelligent alien device
that travels around the galaxy stealing
resources from planets it had its eyes
on the earth for a long time the ship
that julia and jack were in was attacked
by tet but jack managed to detach the
capsule with the hibernation pods before
he and victoria were captured after that
tet made several versions of jack and
victoria and sent them down to take over
humanity their memories were wiped so
they wouldn't question the mission but
beech saw jack save julie and understood
that he was different he finally
welcomes jack back to the human side now
jack repairs the drone that is supposed
to take the explosive to tet and destroy
it but before they can launch it they
are attacked by three other drones a
fight ensues between beach's group and
the drones in which most of their crew
are killed at last beach is gravely hurt
and the drone they were supposed to
launch is also destroyed now jack takes
on the responsibility to get the
explosive to tet julie insists on
joining him so he puts her in a
hibernation pod and the two take off for
ted on his way jack listens to the
flight recording that was retrieved from
julie's ship while listening to it he
remembers what happened on the ship
before they were captured in the present
jack finally reaches the tet and the
doors open for him to enter inside he
sees thousands of jacks being created in
incubation pods he finally comes before
the tet which is a triangular device
jack then opens the hibernation pod in
front of it only to reveal it has beach
inside of it he had left julie safe in
the lake house and brought beach with
him so the tet wouldn't suspect his
intentions he finally sets off the
explosion and destroys the alien device
saving humanity and earth's resources
however both jack and beech die in the
explosion cut to three years later julia
has given birth to jack's daughter and
the two still live in the lake house one
day they are approached by beach's
surviving crew the crew has also brought
jack from tech 52 with it the movie ends
as he meets eyes with julia subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thanks for watching